so I suppose if I go back to the
beginning it I learned about this time
last year when it was first announced
that Kate was pregnant that I would be
covering the royal birth so I was very
excited about that and I did an awful
lot of research ahead of time so I knew
what would happen where she was going to
have the baby I knew what was going to
happen with other people that were
having a baby on the same day and you
about the christening gown and you about
potential godparents everything I could
possibly cram into my little head what I
didn't know was when she was going to go
into labor and so from the beginning of
July when it was sometime in July so
from the beginning of July I didn't move
very far from central London at all and
I had a bag packed at the front door
waiting for the call from the news desk
to say Kate's in labor labor can you
head down to the Lindo wing I was more
prepared for this birth than I was for
my own so I had some cream
I had kugels I had autocue I had
breakfast bars
I had Diet Coke I had my notebook I had
my flat shoes I had a change of clothes
I had everything I could possibly need
and then at 7 o'clock that morning I got
the call saying it appears that she's
gone into labor somebody's seen her
going into the hospital with William and
so that was around about 20 plus 7 I was
there at 8 o'clock to go live on air and
then I broadcast live more or less all
the time apart from a couple of hours
sleep in the middle until we got the
news at around about half-past eight the
following night and then I finished on
our about nine o'clock and I went home
and had the biggest glass of wine you've
ever seen the atmosphere down on the
ground was electric actually everybody
got on incredibly well even though it
was so busy and packed and there were
hundreds of photographers and cameramen
and reporters from all around the world
I mean this was a global occasion so I
just had to squeeze in tight and turn to
one side and could just about still see
the camera but everybody got on
incredibly well as I said and we had an
agreement with the photographers so it
was the cameras first and then the
photographer's in banks on ladders
moving back from them we agreed that
once they came out or indeed any of the
Royals going in or
out all the Middletons we would crouch
down so that they could get a good shot
but on occasion although we were trying
to fill air we would take a commercial
break every now and again and the camera
and would be throwing Percy pigs at us
and we would have a bit of a food fight
you know it was a really fabulous
occasion and when we got the news that
the baby had been born four hours
earlier and we hadn't we hadn't even had
an inkling and that's when everything
erupted it's it's a son we're being told
Anna it's a sunbonnet for 24 p.m. there
were 36 hours when we thought any moment
were going to hear the news that the
baby has been born finally we heard
after about 12 hours or so we finally
heard that the baby had been born and
then we thought potentially she's had a
healthy happy birth at the baby and the
royal couple would come out that night
and go back to Kensington Palace but
when they close those Lindo wing doors
then we knew that wasn't going to happen
so we went and got a quick bit of Kip
and came back the day after and at any
stage that day they could have come out
and so we were literally on tenterhooks
the whole time then we got the
announcement in fact it was Charles who
had noticed that we were there and said
all you've been here a long time and
then when he came out a few minutes
later we thought that was really quick
and we asked him we shouted to him you
know how is everybody and he said you'll
find out in a minute and we thought it's
going to be neither babies coming out so
from that moment we crouched down as
we'd agreed with with the photographers
i sat in a puddle with my white jeans on
had a very wet bottom and sat there for
an hour an hour and a half waiting for
that moment
but eventually when they did come out
and we saw him and he almost did a
little regal wave didn't he as he was
stretching his arms up Prince George
Louis Allen Prince George Alexander
Louie isn't it
he was a whopper what a great big baby
he was but it was all worth it for just
that moment it was a moment in history
and I was there how cool is that
we saw William putting the car seat into
the car Kate got into the back and he
sort of clicked it in like an expert but
he gave it away when he clicked it in
close the door and was just about to get
into the driver's seat in he went and
then admitted later but he had been
sweating it and he had been practicing
for a very long time to try to make sure
that moment went without a hitch and
indeed it did I was incredibly lucky to
have a ringside seat in that moment in
history when a future heir to the throne
was introduced to the world lucky me